Let’s return to 2003, a time before YouTube.
Yes, we know that’s a frightening thought,
we only ask that you take a deep breath and
compose yourself so we can get through the
rest of the story.
While YouTube may not have been invented for
another two years, the burgeoning internet
of the early 2000s still wasn’t without
its content creators, posting everywhere from
basic social media sites, to personal GeoCities
websites and specialty forums.
One of these early proto-content-creators
was a man named John Cutler, better known
at the time by his online handle: Johnstation.
Johnstation was, tragically, a man operating
before his time.
His interests were firmly based on three things:
Mysteries, the paranormal and urban exploration.
If he’d been operating a mere decade later,
he would have made a killing on Urbex videos,
or Scary 3 AM Challenges, but instead, he
was just sharing his urban exploration photos
and videos with a small group of friends on
various niche internet forums - like Parawatch,
a premiere destination for lovers of the strange
and unusual online.
Little did he know, an anomalous being he
was about to encounter was an even more prolific
internet user than him.
But let’s start from the beginning.
Johnstation was making his way to the city
of Detroit, Michigan, on a Greyhound bus.
Detroit had become somewhat of a holy land
for dark tourists, photographers, and urban
explorers - It’d once been one of the most
valuable manufacturing hubs in the United
States, the very heart of the automotive industry
until all of those manufacturing jobs were
outsourced to other countries for cheaper
labor.
This, along with a number of other factors,
led to a devastating economic collapse that
the area is still suffering from today, along
with a huge number of abandoned residential,
commercial, and industrial buildings, just
waiting to be explored.
And Johnstation planned to start off with
a real staple of the Urbex genre: A derelict
warehouse.
He was expecting to get some cool photos of
disused machinery and maybe some cool graffiti
left by anonymous street artists over the
years, but what he certainly didn’t expect
was a series of thirteen massive underground
structures hidden below the warehouse.
Something that looked like it would take decades
to even excavate the room for, let alone actually
build.
The whole thing seemed like some kind of obscenely
massive workshop: Strange machinery, shelves
upon shelves of papers and notes, spare parts
laying around everywhere.
What had happened here?
But as Johnstation continued his search into
the bowels of this labyrinthine warehouse,
he came upon the most strange and disquieting
discovery of all: A large glass jar filled
with green liquid, and a perfectly preserved
human brain floating inside.
Of course, he took some pictures to share
with his forumite buddies and got the hell
out of dodge.
Johnstation had made what was - for any self-respecting
Parawatch-user - a terrible mistake.
Because he was too busy listening to Avril
Lavigne on his big, clunky, early-2000s headphones,
he didn’t hear the brain’s attempt to
communicate with him.
“Oh, hello, young man, are you here to see
my marvelous inventions?
Young man?
Young man?”
But he was already gone by then.
Little did Johnstation know, he’d just encountered
one of the greatest human minds of his generation:
Jeremy Valdez, an inventor without equal.
And what’s more, he may have actually encountered
this singularly intelligent individual before.
Thanks to Jeremy’s brilliant foresight,
and the invention of a little something he
called the V-Wave Universal Ansible, this
disembodied brain was connected to the internet.
What exactly was it doing with that internet
connection?
Everything from being a frequent forum poster
to selling anomalous technology on the deep
web.
While we don’t know much more than that
about the brain’s browsing habits, it goes
without saying that we’d kill to see a copy
of its internet history.
When Johnstation returned home, he posted
a picture of the brain to the internet, telling
his fellow urbex buddies to go and check the
warehouse out.
Naturally, this caught the attention of the
SCP Foundation, who saw a mysterious human
brain hiding in a secretive underground structure
in Detroit to be a certifiably anomalous development.
And really, they didn’t know the half of
what they were about to get into.
Welcome to the mind of Jeremy Valdez.
After all the proper witnesses had been given
amnestic treatment, the Foundation secured
the warehouse and began exploratory missions
into its bowels.
It was exactly as Johnstation reported: A
chaos of junk and shelves upon shelves of
almost incomprehensible notes and diagrams.
While agents searched for the brain of Jeremy
Valdez, they encountered what would later
be known as SCP-2099-B: His wondrous anomalous
creations.
Most of these creations are robotic in nature,
with some of them being known as “Peripherals”
- creations made specifically to help Valdez
continue his research in his disembodied brain
form.
And they weren’t exactly pleased about the
Foundation intruding on Jeremy’s extremely
important research.
They tried to defend his secret lair beneath
the warehouse and were destroyed in the firefight
with Foundation personnel.
Only five peripherals are active now, which
the Foundation uses as collateral in their
deal with Valdez for his continued cooperation.
To put it less politely: If he doesn’t play
ball, then the last of his peripheries get
terminated.
Thankfully for him and the Foundation operatives
assigned to his case, Jeremy is a highly cooperative
anomaly who has consistently behaved pleasantly
towards Foundation staff.
That’s right: He’s able to communicate
directly with others by anomalous means.
However, while having a direct line to the
mind of this enigmatic ball of gray matter
would seem like a dream to your typical researcher,
the cooperation of Jeremy Valdez has been
less valuable than the Foundation initially
believed it would be.
This is largely because Jeremy’s mind appeared
to be pretty similar to his workspace: Strange,
chaotic, and hard to decipher.
When they first asked who exactly he was,
his response was:
"I am the Profound Professor V, the genius
who invented the Quantum Pistol, the Rocket
to Sagittarius, the Window to Other Worlds.
My name is Jeremy Valdez.
Jeremy, there was another Jeremy I met once,
well, lots, but the one stuck in my mind.
Clever man, a salesman.
Can't trust them an inch if you give them
a mile, but that wasn't me."
He’s a little scatterbrained, to put it
politely.
Many of his answers, while strange and amusing,
have been largely useless to the Foundation.
For example, when they asked him how he was
able to construct the secret facility, he
said:
"Oh, dug it all out.
Tricky bit was the supports.
Used solid Valdezium to hold it up.
That's my own invention.
Name trademarked, patent pending, unless I
forgot to send the application."
And when they asked how he was able to survive
as a mere brain in a jar, he had the equally
baffling and frustrating response:
"Good diet and exercise.
Healthy living.
Oh, and the electrolytes.
It's in my notes somewhere, the whole process.
Never will look at mashed potatoes the same
way, I'll tell you that."
There may at least be some truth to that last
one, as the solution inside Jeremy’s jar
has been tested and proven to be water mixed
with electrolytes, sugars, green food coloring,
and artificial flavoring.
The current working theory on the green food
coloring is simply that Jeremy thought it
would make his disembodied brain look cooler.
Jeremy truly proves that the lines between
genius, madness, and outright buffoonery are
far more malleable than any of us could have
imagined.
It’s because of Jeremy’s forgetfulness
that he and his peripheries are such meticulous
note-takers, though there is no discernable
filing system for this absurd multitude of
notes, and the majority of them are written
in a quick and scratchy shorthand that only
Jeremy himself seems able to decipher.
But of course, the most fascinating part of
the story of Jeremy Valdez is his creations,
so now, we’re going to take a better look
at those inventions, and some of the stress
that the Foundation has been going through
in order to track the rest of them down.
The peripherals are a varied bunch.
Some are as simple as a pair of robot hands
that endlessly take notes from Jeremy’s
unstoppable stream of consciousness.
Some are as theatrical as humanoid robots
dressed like butlers - we can’t help but
wonder how Mr. Deeds from SCP-662 would feel
about the extra competition.
However, the peripherals are really just the
tip of the iceberg when it comes to Jeremy’s
overall body of work.
Let’s take a little crash course through
some of the peculiar inventions they discovered
in Detroit.
A pistol that fires out powerful x-rays, inexplicably
powered by two ordinary AA batteries and focused
via a non-anomalous quartz crystal.
A six-meter-tall humanoid robot constructed
primarily from chrome and steel.
A cannon that fires anomalous robot ninjas.
No, that isn’t a joke.
The cannon fires cartridges that anomalously
break open, revealing human-sized robots wielding
swords and nunchucks.
A bin labeled “cyborg parts”, which was
filled with a multitude of cybernetic prosthetic
body parts - though none of these parts had
any mechanisms that would allow them to interface
with the human nervous system.
But wait, there’s more!
A huge excavation vehicle with massive drills
and claws that makes the dirt it displaces
disappear, perhaps explaining how Jeremy managed
this little construction project.
A rocket-based spacecraft with sediment stuck
to its landing gear that indicates it’s
been on the moon at some point in the past.
A forcefield generator so effective that the
Foundation is still unable to penetrate it
because Jeremy himself has - unsurprisingly
- forgotten how to turn it off.
A failed anti-gravity machine that instead
just creates more gravity, meaning anything
or anyone brought into its vicinity becomes
twice as heavy as they would be under the
normal conditions of Earth gravity.
In case you needed a little dose of existential
terror today, there’s also a complete working
simulation of an entire alien solar system,
somehow held on only two gigabytes of memory.
And of course, we wouldn’t be doing Jeremy
Valdez justice if we didn’t tell you how
obsessed he is with lasers.
The Foundation even found a large containment
unit on the site, labeled “713 different
laser guns”, which contained - Yep, you
guessed it - 713 different laser guns.
We imagine at least one or two of these ended
up in the Foundation armory, or at least the
personal office of Dr. Bright - Well, if they
could only figure out how this absurd, ridiculous
technology actually worked.
The most challenging part of containing SCP-2099
isn’t the brain itself - though the picture
of Jeremy’s brain is still circulating out
on the internet today if you know where to
look - it’s finding and containing the anomalous
items that Jeremy left laying around in his
life before containment.
Because Jeremy himself has a brain like a
colander, even finding these items is largely
a result of picking up clues from his bizarre
ramblings, and the thousands of pages of nigh-incomprehensible
notes he won’t stop babbling on about.
While trying to find one of Jeremy’s items
in an alley in Boston, Massachusetts, Foundation
agents ran afoul of a group of Chaos Insurgency
agents searching for the same thing.
But this wouldn’t be the last peculiar tie
between Jeremy and certain groups of interest
pitted against the Foundation.
In a soup kitchen in Seattle, Washington,
the Foundation found that Jeremy had once
sold an enlarger ray to agents of the Manna
Charitable Foundation - A surprisingly benevolent
GOI who use anomalies to help the needy.
They used the enlarger ray to enlarge food
and fight against hunger in the city’s homeless
population.
And while visiting an area in Boise, Idaho,
after Jeremy once mentioned having customers
there, the Foundation discovered substantial
connections to a member of a Serpent’s Hand
cell.
It seemed to all observers that Jeremy was
a kind of anomalous Forrest Gump - a man who
had somehow bungled his way through a series
of unfortunate arrangements with several of
the Foundation’s greatest enemies.
He’s a brain with an awful lot of bad luck.
Or is he?
Because while the Foundation has bought his
bumbling fool schtick hook, line, and sinker,
that doesn’t mean it’s true.
In fact, in a classified letter to a member
of the Serpent’s Hand that worked closely
with him in the past, Jeremy presented a very
different picture of himself…
“Hey, L, I got your letter.
Yeah, I'm not too worried about the SeCoPro.
They're still digging at the old place.
Psychology of the individual, man.
They're like cats.
You run, they're gonna chase you.
But if they see something else moving, that's
where their eyes are, leaving you to jet.
The tail?
Yeah, he's fine.
He's designed for this stuff, man.
And it's not like he's really there or anything.
They get wise, we pull the plug and get away
free and clear.
Anyway, I got some new toys I came up with.
Robots the size of fleas.
They grab onto a guy, get carried wherever.
They record what they see and hear, leave
with whoever, and detach where you need 'em.
No signal to trace, because they don't broadcast.
You get it all when you collect them.
Figure it'll be useful for that project of
yours.
I know, not your usual style, but get with
the times, man.
If you'd care to join me in the 22nd century,
leave payment in the usual place.
Ask Schitz if you don't remember.
And please, man, let me take a look at that
hat.
I just know I can make it better.
You could have goddamned lasers firing off
your head.
Think about it.
V.”
So, what do you think?
Is Jeremy a bumbling brain in a jar, or is
that very brain a decoy for one of the most
ingenious and deceptive masterminds in the
anomalous world, an anomalous Keyser Soze,
always staying one step ahead of the Foundation
while sending its agents on wild goose chases?
Well, the fact we even need to ask shows that
Jeremy Valdez is a few steps ahead of us already...
Now go check out “SCP-5049 - The Skin Salesman
- Demon Dan's Discount Homunculus Depot”
and “A Sea Snail's Fantasy SCP-1867 - A
Gentleman” for more SCPs you could hold
a very interesting conversation with!